peut dire que la vaccination avait été
créée par des sociétés secrètes il nous
un plan des puces là c'est pour ça qu'on
a des marques et après ils nous traitent
ils m ouille coupe pire qu'un gps en des
questions un peu d'humour pour cette
campagne de communication qui cible les
plus réfractaires au vaccin
car dans ce cabinet médical de ducos
même si la famille galles on vaccine la
petite dernière
c'est avec quelques inquiétudes pour
tous nos enfants fait on a toujours
suivi effectivement les calendriers mais
c'est vrai que la dernière génération
bac ça c'est vrai qu'on se pose des
questions
le vaccin une protection contre de
nombreuses maladies invalidantes voire
mortelles un geste vital pour certains
cela fait du bricolage et c'est
important de le savoir tant mieux mais
c'est un geste qui laisse rarement
indifférent à la base mois déjà 11
vaccins au dos je sais plus pour un
nourrisson
pour moi c'est trop déjà 6 3 je pense
que
on n'a pas besoin de tout cela c'est
aussi notre rôle en tant que
professionnels de santé de recommander
la vaccination
on constate aussi une campagne de
désinformation sur les réseaux sociaux
et c'est à nous aussi en tant que
professionnels de santé de faire masse
de faire passer le bon message se battre
contre les idées reçues pour améliorer
la couverture vaccinale
car si les anciens vaccins comme la
diphtérie le tétanos et la poliomyélite
vie pour d'autres
l'objectif est loin d'être atteint en
martinique pour la rougeole 84% de la
population est vaccinée loin des 95%
recommandé conséquence la maladie est
réapparue dans l'hexagone et dans les
pays d'amérique
les jeunes filles l'autre cible de la
campagne d'information car seulement 8%
des femmes sont vaccinés contre le
papillomavirus humain loin des 65 %
conseiller le hpv est pourtant à
l'origine de nombreux cas de cancer du
col de l'utérus
le troisième cancer de la femme en
martinique pas mieux pour la crypte 14 %
de personnes vaccinées dans l'idéal il
faudrait que 75% de la population le
soin surtout chez les personnes fragiles
et les professionnels de santé eux-mêmes
on constate actuellement que les
professionnels de santé dans les
hôpitaux mais aussi dans les maisons de
retraite ou dans les centres qui
accueillent les personnes handicapées ne
sont pas suffisamment vacciner et donc
s'expose eux à la maladie mais
finalement dans seize ans dans cette
atmosphère un peu plus que son ccc
centre expose aussi les patients les
pensionnaires à ce qu'ils développent la
grille de nombreux efforts restent donc
à faire mais quelques pistes sont à
l'étude comme la vaccination des
personnes majeures par des pharmaciens
comme cela se fait déjà dans certains
départements de l'hexagone